wolfram is a place of great innovation
you want to do world-changing work
Wolfram is a great place to start your
career
here at Wolfram we really make room for
passionate and talented students
we treat our interns just as we treat
our full-time employees we really hold
them to a high standard and really
invest in them our interns are really
plugged into real projects they're doing
real work you come to work very exciting
every day because you know you are
surrounded by talented Po and friendly
people and you get to use very advanced
technology in here
if I could describe three words it would
be challenging exciting and rewarding it
was very exciting to work on the
cutting-edge computational technology
that Wolfram is involved and working
with overall it was a very very good
experience that I had over the summer
wolfram has been an extremely unique
opportunity for me mostly because of the
fact that I've here been able to
actually have a true technical
recruiting internship here well from I
do I source I source talent so I go out
and find people for the open positions
we have I conduct interviews and I then
connect those candidates to hiring
managers who are looking to fill those
positions
I've been working in the washing
technology group and what I've been
mostly doing is responding to our
clients emails of all the technical
questions that they may have using our
products mostly Mathematica
I work on welcomes Oracle ERP system so
if I were to say what gr p is to IIT
it's like the nervous system is to the
human body it basically connects the
entire IT departments throughout the
organization and bridges them I've feel
that I want to develop a new program
with an Oracle my managers not going to
stop me from doing it in fact he's going
to encourage me and that's one of the
things I like is that innovation is
encouraged
it's awesome to have all this
responsibility dumped on you and just to
to be able to impact so much
I'm the WolframAlpha chemistry developer
so I get to work on everything from
chemicals ions elements reactions it's a
gigantic database but a big framework
and I just get to fit chemistry nice and
neatly and expanded everywhere and will
for nothing
don't feel hesitated to apply even
though your major is not computer
science or engineering or physics math
degree because as a food science major
here I feel I can contribute to the team
or in my perspective I would advise all
the prospective interns to take
initiatives whenever possible it's been
a really great experience the HR team
has been really helpful I love hearing
about what they want to be when they
grow up from that point on it's my job
to really ensure that their internship
aligns with their career path here at
our company some of our best employees
started out as interns here at with them
and I think that is again a little bit
unique to wolfram we have people at all
levels of the company who came in as
students made their mark and have stayed
because it is a great place to be
you
you